[Musik]
ein luzerner unternehmer kämpft um seine
firma corona bringt das unternehmen zum
stillstand
eine künstlerin muss alles absagen
crailsheim coruna gefährdet ihre
existenz die sozialstunden wurden nicht
aushöhlen zwei luzerner freunde führen
in der touristenstadt ein hotel
sie geben alles um das haus zu retten
ihre geschichten in luzern im corona ja
luzern im corona shutdown
wo sich sonst einheimische und touristen
drängeln nichts als leere
sechs lange wochen
dann nach der ersten welle in mai 2020
erwacht die stadt zu neuem leben im
hotel wo sie mitten in luzern wird mit
elan und optimismus die wiedereröffnung
vorbereitet der start in eine zukunft
von der niemand genau weiß was sie
bringen wird
[Musik]
hoteldirektor manuel berger und sein
geschäftspartner sind froh endlich
wieder loslegen zu können
doch der zurückgewonnenen freiheit
trauern noch nicht alle so ganz wird sie
wenn wir mal so verblieb ich nehms datum
dem fall um sich und sicherte somit zu
einer parkfläche ist die hürde so damit
die bürger macht recht das sechste gebot
des tagesgeschäfts bis 550 gelingt das
heißt natürlich jetzt lag sogar eine
komplette absage
also eigentlich hätten jährige gebürtige
pcs bisschen wie wenn man gar nico und
ich habe es doch man merkt dass ganz
viel umsatz im jahr 2020 unverhofft
findet sich der junge hoteldirektor in
der größten krise unserer zeit wieder
damit hat er nicht gerechnet als er vor
zweieinhalb jahren das bonjour als
pächter übernommen hat der schatten
sitzt auf seinem geschäftspartner walter
willi willi man in den knochen
schockzustand der langsam akzeptiere und
wieso
es gibt alternative das heißt wenn wir
mit positiv sehen das als unternehmer
der mitarbeiter angeht und
schlussendlich gottes stimme
und das schaffen sie nicht desinfiziert
und sagt stroh im historischen hotel
soll das alte erhalten und mit neuem
verbunden werden daran arbeiten weiter
willimann und die gastkünstlerin jener
stelle mit kreativen ideen wollen manuel
und willi das sommergeschäft ankurbeln
um groner bedingte einbußen bei den
übernachtungen witze machen soll ein
kiosk flaneure vom sie anlocken
[Musik]
im ländlichen willisau 30 kilometer von
luzern entfernt ist der größte festzelt
bauer der schweiz zu hause
doch wo keine events stattfinden braucht
es auch keine festzelte
[Musik]
nachdem shutter und herrscht bei roland
kühn den ceo der firma hunziker
krisenstimmung im prinzip läuft
vier jahres sieht muss alles was ihnen
alles groß oder waren große la las jetzt
wo halt mythischen dementsprechend war
am morgen alles büro weiß genau was noch
kein bauarbeiter auf der baustelle sind
und organisatorischer absage
was mit geworden
[Musik]
in normalen zeiten würden seine 70
angestellten jetzt in der ganzen schweiz
fest zelte aufbauen
die lagerhallen wären leer samt oft
irgendwo acht musikstudent tribüne
besteht keine tribüne crash portal auf
nötig alles der heimat
eigentlich müsste also so wie jetzt all
die blogger circa 200.000 quadratmeter
brauchen dass man tiere fast alle decken
alles ist praktisch alles
[Musik]
und eigentlich vorbei
im adel im dornröschenschlaf ich daraus
haben wir nicht und blieb damit ohne
gnade ist und der einzig das glüht
eigenes tempos und der rest ist mein
geschmack ist mit euro am tag im ruf
gehört hat und seitdem kennt alle regeln
alle kurzarbeit so wie zu irgendwie ein
oder dabei war alles vorbereitet für ein
jahr voller events oder material oder
material musik quadratmeter investiert
kauft für saison für alle die auftrag
neues material kauft ihr braucht in
luzerns peripherie in emmenbrücke
am meist befahrenen platz der stadt
steht die älteste schaubude der schweiz
das varieté-theater ist über 70 jahre
alt claudia kienzler hat den verein
gegründet der das variete gekauft hat
und hat damit ein riskantes projekt
übernommen
nach der renovation soll hier das
publikum akrobatik musik theater und
kulinarik genießen können
claudia hätte tausend gute ideen wenn
sie denn loslegen könnten
das stellen wir da einem spielort
darüber haben wir das trapez für die
ganz luftartistik vor der bühne so
genannte im beliebten ort und die beste
aussicht das hat geklappt verschwinden
und einer irgendwo wieder auftauchen
so sei die andere sind gott verboten
links und rechts sind die sechs gäste
platz und die unvorstellbare ob es gott
falls das möglich ist letztes jahr also
zum jetzt gestand fronarbeit das nicht
möglich wenn man die abstände wenn die
halter den wird denn jetzt schwierig
also das ist die planungsunsicherheit
mit denen ich jetzt muss um gott und
logo ist jetzt entwickelt wie es ist
wenn glied vor der sommerferien hat was
denn passiert mit virus oder mit der
pandemie claudia hofft dass sich die
situation bis im herbst 2020 etwas
normalisieren wird und sich die pandemie
als kurzer schrecken erweist bei der
renovation packt die künstlerin am musik
an
wenn ich das machen wir aber freiwillig
gemacht
sämtliches abhaken
die 39 jährige leitet ein dreiköpfiges
team welches das variete wieder auf
vordermann bringt ich bin einfach nicht
so gut sind aber auch die logistik von
ganzen aufbau helfen das variete
tingelte über 70 jahre durchs land auch
claudia für ein paar songs mit dabei mit
der übernahme hat sie die marode bude
vor dem abbruch gerettet das ist zum
teil und logistisch und relativ komplex
ihm ein aufbau ist und mit alten
materialien schafft worden ist es gibt
das es geht der charakter und das flair
denn wer dazu gehört dass man mit werken
und wachsen mit alter wacker mit
traktoren ihre drei angestellten
bekommen einen lohn sich selber können
sie die natur erst nicht auszahlen
hannelore das mini fix recht es ist im
labor anhalt 1000 jetzt als therapie
vater nennen das eigene haus zu haus um
das verteilen bruch auch nicht so
wahnsinnig vielen man sagen mich macht
freiheit mit wenig trennen als vierter
[Musik]
auch die hoteliers discos zu
erwirtschaften derzeit kein einkommen
dafür müssen sie erst wieder gäste haben
in den 28 zimmern seien zu haben ein
schrank und verbringen viel zeit mit
da ist aber wir glauben dass es immer so
viele sachen wurde mit manuel de dion
bouton gast und ich haben als antwort
kann ja aber ist und ich weiß es und
wenn du bist nicht ganz gutes tennis
und das geht ganz gut vom hotel das dass
man so weit schaffen
willi und manuel haben große visionen
manuel hat auch das alltagsgeschäft im
auge
[Musik]
das reinigungspersonal muss sich mit
neuen corona konformen hygienemaßnahmen
vertraut machen
wie genau das geht wirklich um die die
händels fenster türen schränke dosen
licht an auslosen aufgabe haben wir den
affen hotel maskottchen ein wird opfer
der hygienemaßnahmen der kuschel affe
soll keine viren weitergeben können sie
schon einmal ein musik und das ist jetzt
auch diskutiert wurde kontrovers
rezensierte als finanzinstrument hat das
noch nicht wisst operativen manuel
träumte mal davon architekt zu werden
geblieben ist seine liebe zum detail
noch so lang
und wenn s
die terrasse mit dem kiosk und das hotel
sind bereit
morgen ist eröffnung
von einem neustart ist man bei der
zeltbau firma hunziker weit entfernt
seit vier monaten läuft hier fast nichts
mehr
das kein uno hat vor der pandemie stets
die größten events ausgerichtet
jetzt ist sie in euroland künftig jeden
kleinen auftrag sei es für eine hochzeit
oder den samariterverein anzahl der
steigen sich um renten aktionslinie war
seinerzeit größte eigentlich zwölf meter
zehnter 10 25 25 22 und technisches und
ganzen für die ganze woche
ja ich hatte hier immer noch größer
limonen renovieren und verbote noch mehr
geschäfte muss ihre heimat bei der
regungslos spieler
[Musik]
kritik am 10
wo vielleicht ganz schönes wochenende
ankara
[Gelächter]
kurz vor dem showdown investierte das
unternehmen in eine neue waschanlage für
zelt blachen eine viertelmillion hat sie
gekostet
jetzt ist sie nur selten im einsatz
heute alle möglichkeiten der mauer
zwischen ihnen möglich autoarbeiter was
sie steigen nicht möglich wo anderen
abteilungen sind aber ich glaube
grundsätzlich andere bestätigen
er sei noch nie eine oder praktisch nie
einig sagt hohmann die mitarbeiter
sollen beschäftigt werden auch auf lange
sicht
entlassungen sind bei hunziker derzeit
kein thema claudia kienzler ist
ausgebildete klassische musikerin vor
der korona krise ist sie in
verschiedenen formationen mit
klassischer und zeitgenössischer musik
aufgetreten
im luzerner kkl in berlin oder tokio
[Musik]
es geht ich glaube die begleiterinnen es
ist es begleitet sie begleitet mehrere
der kirby zu mir sicher bin dass ich
eine gewisse sanftheit war in ihr ist
sagte sie sturheit also ich habe jetzt
da sich abgesetzt und wenn dann will ich
jetzt das und blieb lieber treu oder sie
bleibt mir treu sie hätten aber sie sind
heute zurückkommen
nun müssen claudia und ihre geige
gemeinsam warten denn im frühsommer ist
kein einziger auftritt in sicht
in normalen zeiten flanieren heerscharen
von touristen durch luzern
jetzt herrscht selbst vor dem
löwendenkmal gähnende leere
gleich daneben findet sich eine filiale
von casa grande den größten
souvenirhändler luzerns robert
casagrande besitz zusammen mit seinem
bruder fünf filialen die aktuell jedoch
kaum kundschaft haben das geschäft mit
den reisenden liegt ihm im blut und hat
seine familie wohlhabend gemacht jetzt
vor den sommerferien hofft doch noch auf
viele gäste hier am grindel war vor der
pandemie kein durchkommen mehr zum
grossen ärger der einheimischen
doch ein gast rande stört sich nicht an
ohne zu wissen
da verstand andré kavai draft sind und
die country minute um die luxusklasse
und sie noch eine versammlung irgendwo
an der nord und die die verschiedenen
geschafft können jetzt verteilen
das ist es so dass meistens ist der
gruppe so blamierte förmig irgendwie der
post ist da hätte relativ viel geld und
da wird sich beim buchen fichten rolex
oder die asche auf und beim berliner
partei pd und sämtliche andere leute
weniger geld ankomme dazu und kaufe dir
normaler sowie die
und das nachdem das sie für
sicherheitskräfte aber wegen coruna
läuft am rendl gar nichts
der ur luzerner casagrande kennt die
ganze stadt auf dem samstagsmarkt der
jetzt wieder möglich ist trifft man sich
wie vor den shutdown keine personen
beschränkungen keine masken und licht in
dieses hotel organisiert und hat im golf
gruppe auf später
[Musik]
selbst den gemüsehändler fehlen die
touristen casagrande ist ein luzerner
original natürlich über die story
patenverein aus statt im vorstand
präsident und natürlich
[Musik]
der 66 jährige pflegt einen lockeren
umgang auch beim händischen vielleicht
auch beeinflusst durch die derzeit
tiefen neuansteckungen von nur gerade 26
[Musik]
im mai 2000 20 treffen im luzerner hotel
bosse uhr die ersten gäste nach dem
showdown ein
nach langen wochen zu hause kennen sie
endlich wieder reisen und vermisstes
nachholen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
die hotelgäste fabienne märki und ihr
mann haben etwas wichtiges zu feiern
wir haben charakter hat
dank damit machen
[Musik]
endlich
draußen
[Musik]
der betrieb läuft und der 35-jährige
hoteldirektor blüht auf in seiner rolle
als gastgeber auch das fragte ich sehe
das ist aber dass manuel verlässt sich
auf seine drei mitarbeitenden die er
unbedingt im hotel behalten bis vom weg
standen
das oberste ziel das man nicht mit meter
weiter es ist ein hauptteil der versucht
man alle sind happy hour ausgestattet
die meisten hotelgäste stammen aus der
schweiz ausländische touristen sind
selten dem puzzle gelingt es aber auch
passanten von der seepromenade in den
neu eingerichteten sommer kiosk zu
locken
[Musik]
manuel hilft aus wo es ihnen gerade
braucht war küche rezession
hauptsache nah bei den gästen je mehr
menschen es sich im buch gemütlich
machen
umso gelassener wirkt der hotelier
[Musik]
nur im back office gibt es ein kleines
drama ein kurzschluss jede frage die
infrastruktur sandwich produziert viel
strom
aber zusammen meistern sie das malheur
und das fazit des tages fällt positiv
aus wer handys für moden reise der
wiederaufbau nach den üblichen war sehr
verliebt insgesamt sind dafür bekannt
die züchter aus lausanne wo es ist schon
viel los in zürich und die zahlung mit
recht zuversichtlich also ich freue mich
auf die kommende zeit
ich glaube darauf was man wartet bis los
haben wir sagen wenn es eine konstante
gibt im corinna jahr dann ist es seine
und planbarkeit
[Musik]
von einem aufschwung ist bei der firma
hunziker in willisau nichts zu spüren
seitdem shutdown plant kein veranstalter
ein großes event mehr zu unsicher zu
viel risiko sagte jung und seit dem 28
februar gott sagt was man ja oder
weniger so und das ist eine extrem lange
zieht es geht auch von ups und sage ich
jetzt zwar mittlerweile ob seit ein paar
wenige sind verschoben auf die orangen
und alles was rote shops itunes store
oder anbieter im abo svs aktiv oder eine
bank und großfirmen womit sie faktisch
alles abgesagt wurde
schwingfest wo die säntis ok wm trocken
festival greenfield festival so grob
seitwärts prozent vom jahresumsatz
praktisch so dass ihr euch nicht auf
noch nie hat das 85-jährige unternehmen
so schwierige zeiten erlebt
nur vereinzelt gibt es für den zeltbauer
kleinere aufträge auszuführen
[Musik]
ja liebe 30 jahren hier so passieren
aber mehr angestellte wie ein echter
blogger ist immer studenten rutscht oder
schlechter und mini hoffnung ihre
herrschaft sport herbst sicher
winterwetter aber weiß dass es auch
schnell zwischen so klinge nur große
grus grus grus 270 liter kommen und das
gibt's nicht so dass ich nicht umhin
sich wer ist der clevere absolut nicht
[Musik]
mit dem kauf des varietés ist musikerin
claudia kienzler zur unternehmerin
geworden
sie trägt die verantwortung für drei
angestellte
im atelier brütet die 39-jährige über
budgets und versucht geld für ihre
kultur projekt aufzutreiben
gottseidank mirka juli das kabinett das
zaghafte das neue unternehmen bin
begeistert wie drückt ist von der
stiftung glaubt man ihren so
erfolgreiches fundraising betriebe und
haben so jetzt elf die vor der küste von
investitions leistungen einer decke
bis jetzt und doch fehlen für den
betriebs ausbau knapp 200000 franken
einnahmen durch veranstaltungen sind
keine in sicht und mit konzerten kann
claudia momentan kein geld verdienen und
dass sich nehmen über zügig den hinteren
trauer in not hilft für schoko auch
locker wenn ich mit meinem job von dem
ihm in der situation auch einen spruch
davon oder das beanspruche
ein teilzeitjob als dozentin an der
musikhochschule luzern hilft claudia
finanziell über die runden zu kommen
während des shuttle online unterricht
möglich jetzt trifft sich die klasse zum
didaktik unterricht wieder physisch
[Musik]
was sind die mittel dass der bogen
wechsel schön gewinnt also zeit gehört
euch einfach mit dem instrument könnte
sprechen wird auf zehn minuten seine
schwerpunkte motorisch an der spitze ist
einfach
[Musik]
oder doch eine woche später kam es
zwangsläufig dass sie soll ihn geht ist
also das ganze mit mit zusammen nur
werden entwickeln dass ihr besuch extrem
schwierig mitteilen
was wir haben herausgefunden dass
eigentlich die meiste arbeit im kleinen
finger geschieht also hier und das ist
auch wichtig ist dass er immer auf der
stange bleibt die hat also immer logisch
nach stabilität aber sind ja alle dabei
praktisch weil ich finde es besser sei
es ganz einfach gedacht nicht dass man
bei so praktische sache zusammen also
genug besprechen so es schwieriger video
[Musik]
also ab sie davor die situation extrem
gern machen mit der studierendenschaften
die form von interaktiven unterricht bin
ich froh darum gesetzescharakter zieht
oder immer noch zwar immer noch
verdienst lose zieht als musikverleger
musiker wo weiterläuft und mehr die
absicht ein großteil wurde fix kosten
deckt
eine beruhigende tatsache denn nach wie
vor sind alle konzerte wegen corona
gestrichen
in willisau erscheint es bei der
hunziker ag ein guter tag zu werden
roland köln erwartet seine
berufskollegen um einen verband zu
gründen und dann gibt es auch noch
positive news vom bundesrat bundesrat pk
abstandsregler werden 50 polizisten wäre
sehr wichtig und veranstaltungen und
versammlungen beste musik personen sind
momente wieder erlaubt super geht
hoffentlich werde ich die größe große
geschichte wo ab sind die blieb wieder
abgesagt aber es getroffen dass noch
vier mal wieder hoffnung auf kollege
warte auf die geschäftsführer von vier
festzelt baufirmen treffen ein behältnis
comedia trotz kräftig wirkt da bist du
schon bist du ja praktisch nicht mehr
unter strom oder morgen positiv arbeitet
rockstar sein wenn wir sehr liebten
glaubt drei wochen schon zum teil
das geht in richtung definitiv mein herz
ist der stoff ist mit einem verband
wollen die branchenkollegen auf ihre
schwierige lage aufmerksam machen
als konkurrenten werden verbündete
es gibt themen die kann eine firma
alleine nicht stemmen wir haben über
arbeitssicherheit gesprochen gesprächen
über über general arbeitsverträge sowie
die spieße auch gleich lang sind und
professionalisierung der branche und das
geht eigentlich nur wenn man ihre stimme
haben sagte der man-sprecher
elefantentreffen eine sache überspitzt
gesagt oder war doch größere vor der
branche um 1/100 sich im august im
positiven sinne auch gespürt da anders
tätig ist also wie sie miteinander
abstimmen
aber seit er als stadtrat zustimmen soll
das bitte mit anderen wird sie von
tectum gegründet dass man es fast
applaudieren
[Applaus]
[Musik]
doch schon in der nächsten folge wächst
die verzweiflung bei roland könnten
jetzt mit zusatzmaßnahmen entspricht
sprechers auch an personalkosten aber
sprechen entlassungen
auch die musikerin claudia kienzler
spürt die folgen der krise die vielen
selbst abgesagt und die betreiber des
hotels bonjour bangen um die
sommersaison russland und das gut so und
dass gott sehr schnell
du musst hoffe sie auf die -
[Musik]